La energía nuclear es como las hamburguesas.
No son precisamente lo mejor para nuestra
salud pero ¿quién no se come una de vez
en cuando? Pues con la energía nuclear pasa
lo mismo. Todos consumimos un poquito de electricidad
generada por nucleares. Ahora bien, si las
hamburguesas tienen mala fama, las centrales
nucleares la tienen peor. Sobre todo en Europa.
Ninguna fuente de energía es tan controvertida.
En VisualPolitik ya hemos visto en este otro
video como China está construyendo centrales
nucleares como si no existiera mañana. Pues
bien, en Europa pasa todo lo contrario.
Francia sigue siendo la mayor potencia atómica
del continente. De hecho es el país del mundo
que más depende de sus centrales nucleares.
Pero, en los últimos años, todos esos reactores
están dando más problemas que otra cosa…
Los inspectores encuentran irregularidades
de seguridad en la forja nuclear de Creusot
en Francia
En Reino Unido tenían pensado construir 6
centrales nucleares pero, al final, se va
a quedar en solamente una. En Italia dijeron
adiós a la nuclear en 1990 tras un referéndum.
Y en España su futuro está en cuestión
tras el cambio de Gobierno. En este caso,
España tiene 7 reactores nucleares. Pues
bien, el gobierno socialista dice que quiere
cerrarlos a medida que cumplan 40 años de
funcionamiento. Esto supondría el apagón
nuclear en menos de una década.
Pero todo son paños calientes. Si hay un
país antinuclear por antonomasia, ese es
ALEMANIA. Dentro de 3 años habrán cerrado
ya todos sus reactores nucleares. Para que
os hagáis una idea, en menos de una década,
los alemanes habrán cerrado 17 reactores.
Así que la pregunta es ¿Cómo van a producir
energía los alemanes a partir de ahora? ¿Quién
ha sido el principal beneficiado por esta
decisión? Es más, ¿Cómo puede volverse
en contra del medio ambiente una decisión
que seguramente firmaría cualquier ecologista?
Hoy vamos a responder a todas estas preguntas
pero antes… Vamos a ver un poco de historia.
ANGELA Y SUS DEMONIOS
Si la energía nuclear es como las hamburguesas,
Alemania se puso a dieta en 2011. Y os preguntaréis
¿Pero tan mal estaban, que necesitaban semejante
dieta nuclear? Vamos a compararlos con sus
vecina FRANCIA. En Francia hay 58 reactores
nucleares que producen el 75% de la electricidad.
Sin embargo, hasta 2011, Alemania tenía sólo
17 reactores que producían poco más del
20% de le energía que consumía el país.
En otras palabras, no parece que Alemania
necesitara cerrar las nucleares tan rápido
¿verdad? ¿Por qué tienen tanta prisa? La
respuesta está en una palabra: FUKUSHIMA.
Si recordáis, en el año 2011, un tsunami
golpeó una central nuclear japonesa. La central
de Fukushima. Así es como se desencadenó
uno de los peores accidentes nucleares de
la historia.
Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando ¡En Alemania
no tienen ni terremotos ni tsunamis! ¿Dónde
está el problema?
Para responder a esta pregunta tenemos que
ir más atrás en el tiempo. Los años 60
fueron la era de oro de las centrales nucleares.
Por aquellos años, Alemania estaba dividida
en dos países: el Oeste, que era capitalista
y el Este que era comunista.
En el Oeste, General Electric instaló las
primeras centrales. Después, otras empresas
como la alemana Siemens empezaron a sacar
sus propios reactores. Sin embargo, en el
Este las centrales nucleares estaban construidas
por macroempresas estatales.
Para que os hagáis una idea, Alemania del
Este estaba encantada con la energía nuclear
¿Por qué? Pues básicamente, porque tenían
sus propias minas de uranio. Es más, Alemania
oriental era el cuarto productor de uranio
del mundo.
Mientras tanto, en el oeste también había
alguna mina pero no nos engañemos: la mayor
parte del uranio utilizado venía de Canadá
y Australia.
Y así llegamos hasta el año 1986 ¿Qué
pasó en el año 1986? ¡Exacto! El accidente
de Chernobyl. El peor accidente nuclear de
la historia. Mucho peor que el de Fukushima,
tanto en víctimas mortales como en impacto
ecológico.
Para entonces ya había en Alemania un potente
movimiento antinuclear. De hecho tras años
de protestas habían logrado incluso impedir
la construcción de una central nuclear.
Pues bien, tras Chernobyl, Alemania del Oeste
dejó de construir nucleares para siempre.
Es más, una de las condiciones que exigieron
a Alemania del Este durante la reunificación
fue que cerrasen todas sus centrales.
Para que os hagáis una idea, por aquella
época, había una planta en construcción
en en una ciudad que se llama STENDAL. Pues
bien, pararon las obras en seco y… nunca
se han vuelto a retomar. Básicamente, tras
Chernobyl, nadie más confiaba en la seguridad
nuclear de los soviéticos.
¡Pero aquí no termina la cosa! Veréis,
tanto movimiento antinuclear desembocó en
un partido político: LOS VERDES. Y atentos
porque este partido es muy importante. Tanto
que durante los años 90, terminaron gobernando
en coalición con los socialdemócratas ¿Os
acordáis del señor GERHARD SCHRODER? Hemos
hablado de él en otros vídeos. Pues bien,
este canciller alemán estaba apoyado por
Los verdes. Y por eso, una de sus medidas
fue anunciar el apagón nuclear para el año
2021. Básicamente, quería acortar la vida
útil de las centrales hasta los 32 años.
Sin embargo, en 2010, ya con el gobierno de
Ángela Merkel, cambiaron de planes. Donde
SCHRODER había dicho 2021, Merkel dijo 2036.
15 años más de energía nuclear.
¿Qué ocurrió entonces? Creo que ya os lo
podéis imaginar.
¡Exacto! El accidente de Fukushima. Las autoridades
alemanas revisaron pieza a pieza los 17 reactores
que operaban en el país y no encontraron
ningún problema de seguridad. Pese a todo
esto, Merkel fue inflexible: dio 3 meses de
plazo para cerrar los 8 reactores más antiguos.
Además estableció un calendario de cierre
progresivo para el resto de plantas nucleares.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Por qué Alemania fue
el único Gobierno del mundo que actuó así?
Pues ya os podéis imaginar la respuesta:
MIEDO. Pero no a los tsunamis y a las fugas
radioactivas, sino a las urnas.
Por primera vez, en las elecciones de 2009,
los dos grandes partidos alemanes no llegaban
ni al 60% de los votos. A eso hay que añadirle
que, tras Fukushima el movimiento antinuclear
estaba on FIRE. Y con ellos, el partido de
los verdes.
Así que Merkel pensó que lo mejor que podía
hacer era quitar el debate nuclear de la escena
política y ser más tajante que nadie: para
el 2022 Alemania deja de tener centrales nucleares.
Punto pelota.
Y ahora os estaréis preguntando. ¿Funcionó
la estrategia? Pues sí y no. A corto plazo,
los verdes perdieron fuelle y Merkel se ha
mantenido en el poder. Ahora bien, las cosas
están empezando a cambiar.
La frágil coalición de Alemania camino de
descomponerse con Los Verdes y la extrema
derecha preparados para sacar partido
Pero esperad un momento, porque no solo hablamos
de política. En realidad… detrás del movimiento
antinuclear también hay mucho negocio que
hacer ¿No me creéis? Pues ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver.
¿NUCLEAR? NEIN, DANKE
Imagina que te pones a dieta y dejas de comer
hamburguesas. Un día miras el frigorífico
y dices “bueno, como ya no como hamburguesas…
me puedo dar el capricho de comerme este helado”.
Un mes después, estás comiendo 3 helados
al día y tu dieta se va a freír churros.
Pues eso es lo que está haciendo Alemania.
Ahora mismo lo vais a entender.
Como país, creo que podemos ser pioneros
en la creación de un nuevo período de energías
renovables. Y podemos, como potente nación
industrializada, alcanzar tal transformación
hacia las energías eficientes y renovables…
Aquel día comenzó en Alemania la llamada
Energiewende. La Transición Energética.
Básicamente, Alemania apostaba por las energías
renovables y, a la vez, reducir sus emisiones
de CO2 para la lucha contra el cambio climático.
En 8 años el cambio ha sido nachovidaliano:
la nuclear ha pasado de generar el 22% de
la electricidad al 12%. Las renovables han
pasado del 17% al 35%. Sin embargo, las energías
renovables tienen un problema. A día de hoy,
es muy caro almacenar la energía. Eso significa
que las placas solares sólo dan electricidad
por el día. Y algo parecido pasa con los
parques eólicos. Sin embargo, los alemanes
necesitan electricidad a todas horas ¿Qué
hacemos entonces?
Pues bien, una alternativa sería el gas natural.
Pero si lleváis mucho tiempo suscritos a
VisualPolitik, ya sabéis que el gas natural
tiene muchos problemas políticos. En este
vídeo ya os contábamos cómo Alemania tiene
una enorme dependencia del gas ruso ¿Qué
queréis? ¿Qué dependan aún más de Rusia?
¡Pues menuda solución!
Así que nada, tachamos el gas natural ¿Qué
otra alternativa nos queda? Pues, básicamente,
la menos ecológica de todas…
El lignito obtiene un indulto en la transición
de Alemania hacia un futuro verde
Es un hecho. La industria del lignito alemán
está siendo una de las grandes triunfadoras
del Energiewende. El lignito es un tipo de
carbón mineral. Resulta que Alemania es el
mayor productor de lignito del mundo. De hecho,
con esto de la ENERGIEWENDE, Alemania ha podido
garantizar la estabilidad de 20.000 trabajos.
Y las empresas del sector están de enhorabuena
¿El problema? Que el carbón es el combustible
fósil que más CO2 emite cuando se quema.
Y dentro de todos los tipos de carbón que
existen, el lignito es el más contaminante
de todos… mucho más que la antracita y,
por supuesto, mucho más que el gas natural.
Pues bien, a día de hoy, el lignito está
generando el 23% de la electricidad. ¡Es
más! En realidad es mucho más. Si sumamos
el carbón que importa Alemania, al final
tenemos unos números que llegan al 35%.
En otras palabras, si el objetivo de Alemania
era contaminar más y generar más cambio
climático… ¡Entonces enhorabuena! Todo
apunta a que ese lignito tan contaminante
va a ser cada vez más importante. Y eso explica
noticias como esta.
Alemania no alcanzará los objetivos de 2020
en emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
Fukushima y el Acuerdo de París contra el
cambio climático son dos hechos que prácticamente
han coincido en el tiempo. Y Alemania nos
está enseñando que ningún país con crecimiento
económico puede cerrar al mismo tiempo las
centrales nucleares y las centrales térmicas
de carbón. Es o una cosa, o la otra. Y si
pensabais que el drama energético alemán
termina aquí, esperad porque no habéis visto
nada. Como ya hemos dicho varias veces, la
energía nuclear es cara de instalar pero
muy barata de producir. Renunciar a las centrales
nucleares sube bastante la factura de la luz.
Si a eso le sumamos que las energías renovables
todavía no son, precisamente baratas, tenemos
noticias como esta.
La columna vertebral de la economía de Alemania
sufre los crecientes precios de la energía
Así que la pregunta ahora es para vosotros…
¿Hasta qué punto Alemania seguirá adelante
con la Energiewende teniendo en cuenta su
pérdida de competitividad? ¿Cuál sería
vuestra prioridad: cerrar las centrales nucleares
o las térmicas? Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta
en los comentarios.
Y, por supuesto, no olvidéis que sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas, así que
suscribíos a VisualPolitik y dadle a la campanita
para no perderos ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo. ¡Un abrazo y
hasta pronto!